[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité
la dernière ligne droite pour les
candidats au baccalauréat avant la
redoute et épreuve de philosophie
mercredi prochain les lycéens se prépare
et passent déjà leur première matière
reportage dans les pas d'un candidat
devient atv dès le début de ce journal
et si vous passiez de l'essence ou du
diesel à l'électrique la tendance
retrofit se développe dans l'automobile
c'est le cas notamment en bretagne comme
nous montrera tébéo la chaîne du groupe
le télégramme dans un instant autre
tendance que nous vous ferons découvrir
dans ce journal celle du vin en canette
une exploitation girondine vient de
lancer cette production d'un nouveau
genre
objectif séduire à notre public nous
dira tv7 la chaîne du groupe sud ouest
fort comme un boeuf vous connaissez
c'est sur l'expression est bien elle se
démontre de plus en plus dans nos champs
la rédaction de vos jeux télévision nous
parlera en fin de journal de la traction
animale
c'est un rituel de la vie étudiante les
épreuves du baccalauréat ont déjà débuté
pour les élèves en terminale
professionnelle la fameuse épreuve de
philosophie elle c'est mercredi prochain
et quelle que soit la filière les élèves
entament leur dernière ligne droite dans
les révisions heureusement dans ce
moment si important ils peuvent parfois
compter sur le soutien de leurs proches
exemple avec la rédaction de via à tv en
martinique qui a suivi la préparation
matinale d'un candidat reportage signé
rob aparis et luis régis
croissant pastèque et orange un petit
déjeuner de champion pour alan avant de
prendre la direction du lycée il se
prépare ce matin pour son épreuve
d'histoire géographie le soutien de sa
famille lui permet d'évacuer la pression
un peu stressée après jc de
de will et le stress mais ça va je sais
qu'il va réussir il a poussé le sont ils
faits et louis vi bière voilà je conçois
s'occupent un brin superstitieux le
jeune homme se met en confiance avant le
départ
[Musique]
un tee shirt de la victoire c'est pour
la crise et puis oui j marocaine
puis vient le moment d'y aller
petit contretemps il faut faire demi
tour allan a oublié un document dans sa
chambre pas d'inquiétude maman veille au
grain on va toujours vérifier que tout
est ok sinon voilà
c'est le cas voilà donc j'ai demandé et
là il savait qu'il a oublié sa carte
d'identité cette fois c'est la bonne sur
la route il est encore temps de faire
quelques révisions le lycée elle lâche
pas ses fiches on a visité au moins
trois fois dans l'année donc
j'espère que ça va tomber sur ça vient
après j'ai visé le reste mais j'espère
plus que ces magouilles
arrivée au lycée professionnel du robert
où se déroulent les épreuves les élèves
reçoivent de précieux conseils avant de
plancher
vous avez des comptes regarder les
courses de montech
vous avez au moins la moitié des points
qui sort qui se trouve déjà dans prenez
le temps les sujets arrivent sous
scellés avant d'être distribués aux
jeunes c'est parti pour quatre heures
d'examen
[Musique]
comme alan ils sont plus de 200 à passer
le bac pro cette année une semaine
d'examens pour ces jeunes l'an dernier
96 % des candidats ont décroché leur
diplôme
voilà évidemment bonne chance à tous les
candidats et candidates qui passent leur
baccalauréat cette année bon courage
le reste de l'actualité marquée vous le
savez par les inquiétudes concernant la
sécheresse en france actuellement plus
d'une vingtaine de départements font
l'objet d'une restriction sur les usages
de l'eau parmi les territoires
surveiller celui de la sarthe sur place
la situation n'est pas encore alarmante
mais reste préoccupante propos et
l'image d'anthony picton pour lm tv
sarthe vous voyez qu'il ya quelques
rochers qui dépasse un petit peu de ça
et là et la rangée de rochers qui est
encore un peu plus loin et
habituellement c'est à eux de l'année
c'est assez rare qu'on les voit on les
voit même quasiment pas on est
aujourd'hui très loin d'avoir des
rivières qui coulent avec un débit
naturel on en prélève une part
significative et donc effectivement ça
comme et en impact de venir mettre en
place ces restrictions puisqu'on va
permettre au milieu de souffler un petit
peu pas forcément de se reconstituer
tout de suite puisque on est quand même
dans des périodes où il fait encore
extrêmement sait qu'ils vont un peu de
réalimentation mais on va en tout cas
limiter les dégâts et éviter que ça se
dégrade encore plus
plus de masques dans la rue ni dans les
transports plus de queue pour se faire
tester ou se faire vacciner la crise de
lakovic 19 est elle terminée pour de bon
difficile de le dire encore avec
l'apparition ici ou là de nouveaux
variants une chose est sûre en revanche
le virus ne connaît pas les frontières
dans la loire vous allez le voir les
services de la rs ont décidé d'organiser
une session de vaccination pour les
déplacés ukrainien vingt-et-une
personnes ont ainsi pu bénéficier d'une
première deuxième ou troisième dose du
vaccin céline r6 lee a été sur place
pour la rédaction de tl7 regarder ces
dont le bâtiment aile de l'hôpital de
firminy que s'organise aujourd'hui une
session vaccination des réfugiés
craignent un tout a été pensé pour
faciliter l'exercice
les formulaires ont été traduit en
ukrainien et olga est là pour
interpréter ce sont les services de la
rs qui ont proposé aux ukrainiens de
l'ondaine de participer et il faut
s'adapter à tous les cas de figure
toutes les situations on a des personnes
qui étaient déjà vaccinées mais avec des
vaccins pas forcément reconnu en france
donc on croise un vaccin notamment le
vaccin freezer ici ou des personnes qui
avaient reçu simplement une dose et on
complète le schéma vaccinal comment
ferais pour n'importe quelle autre
personne 21 ukrainiens ont répondu
présents aujourd'hui sans hésitation
c'était important pour moi j'étais pas
vaccinés à l'eau claire c'est très
important fini moi pour ma santé pour la
santé des enfants et
pas seulement
et et pouvoir travailler et pour
l'équipe la vaccination est une machine
bien rodée le docteur jacques
charbonnier vaccine plus vite que son
ombre
depuis trois mois il a pris en charge la
santé des réfugiés de firminy il était
temps de proposer cette vaccination
alors la vaccination sap a été la
priorité
en premier à la priorité ça a été de
rétablir les traitements et puis ensuite
on est quand même en france et le covin
n'est pas éradiquée on en parle moins et
c'est comme vous a dit donc notre
affirme hier c'est très très difficile
de trouver un centre de vaccination dans
la vallée blondel c'est pour ça que j'ai
insisté pour qu'on recrée une séance cet
après midi certains réfugiés devront
faire une dose de rappel d'ici quelques
semaines la rs envisage d'organiser
d'autres journées de vaccination pour
les ukrainiens laurent berger était
l'invité de l'émission face aux
territoires jeudi dernier sur tv5 monde
le secrétaire général de la cfdt a été
notamment interrogé sur le rôle actuel
des syndicats dans la vie sociale du
pays regardez cet extrait de laurent
berger toutes les enquêtes d'opinion et
on va en sortir une au moment du congrès
montrent que la confiance dans les
organisations syndicales et
particulièrement la cfdt est en
progression constante
la dernière enquête du cevipof tic les
orientations syndicales il ya 38 % de
citoyens qui qui qui leur font confiance
à retenir c'est que 38% mais ces dix
points aux 20 points au dessus des
politiques et 10 mois aux 20 points au
dessus et les médias ans et dont vous
pouvez agir concrètement on peut agir
mais on l'est on le fait quand on
obtient des augmentations salariales la
dernière et il entend lancer dans la
propreté pour augmenter les minimum de
branche pour qu'ils soient au dessus du
smic on améliore la situation concrète
quand on se bat pour de meilleures
conditions de travail où vous avez ou
des augmentations de salaires dans telle
ou telle entreprise on obtient les
avancées complète le problème si vous
voulez c'est ce que vous avez dit dans
votre question c'est l'hyper
centralisation on a l'impression que ce
qui n'existe en france ému au
l'hypercentralisation sinon c'est ma
selick c'est pas ça serait trop facile
de le dire comme ça il y a une part de
responsabilité
c'est cette idée que le nous ne
pourrions trouver les solutions aux
préoccupations que rencontrent les
travailleurs les français qu'au niveau
national avec des grandes décisions et
bien non ça ne se passe pas comme ça il
ya beaucoup de choses qui se passent
dans les territoires dans les
entreprises dans les administrations
là vous les gens vivent
voilà et face aux territoires avec
laurent berger est à voir ou revoir sur
les sites internet de nos partenaires
ouest france nice matin 20 minutes
france antilles et la montagne tout à
fait autre chose une inflation élevée et
des chiffres du chômage qui continue de
baisser l'économie française se trouve
actuellement dans une situation peu
commune parmi les secteurs qui recrutent
celui de la porcelaine à limoges ville
par excellence de la porcelaine une
entreprise recherche en ce moment dit
nouveaux salariés un sujet d'alain druot
pour la chaîne 1,7 à limoges
une pyramide des âges qui a accéléré le
renouvellement du personnel une
méconnaissance des métiers de
l'industrie pour ce lainière et voici
les manufactures en plein de candidats
haviland n'échappe pas au phénomène et
recrutent immédiatement dix personnes
dont six au décor nous sommes à la
recherche de nombreux profils en
particulier des profils des calcaires
des quelques donc ce sont les personnes
que vous voyez ici dans cette dans cet
atelier qui déposent les chromos sur les
produits sur les assiettes sur les
tasses sur les pièces de formes
qui ensuite passez à la crise ont pour
donner toute sa splendeur la pièce des
formations existent mais l'entreprise
prend aussi le pari de recruter des
néophytes et de les former la formation
n'a pas forcément été
aussi intenses qu'elles auraient dû pour
maintenir ses savoir faire elle existe
fort heureusement mais elle n'est pas
suffisante aujourd'hui devant la
nécessité le recrutement importante en
dix ans les conditions de travail ont
évolué pour redonner de l'attractivité
aux métiers nous sommes sur des salaires
qui sont sûrs 13 mois haviland
à une organisation qui permet aux gens
notamment
ala décalque de ne travailler que quatre
jours et demi par semaine à la
manufacture sur la partie fabrication
les gens travaille quatre jours par
semaine la société est en plein
renouveau les candidats doivent
contacter directement la manufacture
pour une embauche dans les meilleurs
délais
connaissez-vous la tendance retrofit il
ne s'agit pas de musique ou de mode mais
d'une pratique automobile en clair le
retrofit consiste à remplacer le moteur
thermique d'une voiture par des
batteries électriques une solution de
plus en plus prisé en france avec la
flambée des prix de l'essence une
solution aussi qui pourrait s'imposer
avec la transition énergétique
un reportage en bretagne de tébéo la
chaîne du groupe le télégramme sur place
cet utilitaire à plus de 10 ans et
fonctionne sans bruit et pour cause il
est électrique idem pour 7 504 coupé de
1970 des véhicules thermiques anciens
qui n'ont plus de moteurs essence mais
des batteries sous le capot c'est le
retrofit le retrofit avait été interdite
depuis 1954 donc d'être faisable en
france avec un accord constructeur qu'il
fallait pour pouvoir changer une
motorisation et c'est ce que nous avons
cassé en créant la filière du rétrofit
électrique et en créant une
réglementation avec le ministère des
transports de l'écologie et tous les
services de mme obligations la société
qui installe ses moteurs électriques
fait un tour de france pour convaincre
des bénéfices du rétrofit le retrofit
séduit cette famille prêt à en faire une
activité professionnelle ça permet dans
un premier temps d'éventuellement
continue à faire rouler des véhicules
anciens qui donc ont des vieilles
technologies
et qui à cause des noms des nouveaux
critères d'entrée en ville n'ont plus le
droit de rouler donc ça peut
éventuellement éviter de laisser prendre
la poussière dans un entrepôt autre
avantage du rétrofit son coût par
rapport à l'achat d'un véhicule neuf
électrique ce qui a séduit la banque
partenaire du tour le retrofit présente
le grand avantage d'être moins onéreux
que l'achat d'un véhicule neuf à peu
près la moitié est donc ça permettra à
des populations qui ont des moyens plus
limités de d'accéder un transport propre
avec une solution de financement adaptée
selon l'ademe le retrofit représente un
marché français potentiel d'un milliard
d'euros pour convertir 65 mille
véhicules thermiques en véhicules
électriques dans les cinq prochaines
années
voilà et puis il y a des choses qui ne
semble jamais changé à roland garros à
mettre règne depuis plus de 15 ans et
bien sûr l'espagnol rafael nadal mais au
delà des exploits sportifs le tournoi
parisien est aussi connu pour sa terre
battue cette fascinante couche orange
est produite dans l'oise à partir de
briques un savoir-faire chasse gardée
d'une entreprise qui s'exporte dans le
monde entier à reportage d'agathe poulet
pour ou et aux tv la chaîne de la voix
du nord regarde et on fait comme ça
et après le doigt marqué comme ça
cette terre orange est l'un des symboles
emblématiques de roland garros dans
cette entreprise gresser produits
soixantaine de terre battue pour ce
grand tournoi chaque année cette usine
picard produits 2000 tonnes de terre
battue à partir de briques venant du
nord un processus et un savoir faire qui
demande de la patience pour avoir une
terre de qualité j'ai allumé le broyeur
et je vais retourner le tapis on a
préalablement remplie avec a produit un
peu con caté
donc après ça va aller dans le broyeur
et ça va en sortir par ici c'est tout un
procédé sa part de la brique ont droit
au broyeur bien deux ag as
un mélange à faire ça reste que de la
brique il ya aussi un taux d'humidité à
respecter qui est très très important
que ce soit au niveau du broyage ou au
niveau du conditionnement
fournisseur historique de roland garros
c'est une grande fierté pour cet employé
de fabriquer cette terre battue sur
laquelle les joueurs internationaux sans
fonte c'est un aboutissement de battues
travail qu'on a qu'on fournit
d'enseignants lusine pour pour en
arriver à ce résultat et on voit des
très grands joueurs jouer sur cette
terre ça fait super plaisir
cette fine couche de brique pilée made
in france est importé à travers le monde
entier comme en chine ou au brésil
il est l'une des personnalités préférées
des français son travail son humour et
ses compétences font rêver petits et
grands le spationaute thomas pesquet
était il ya quelques jours à la cité de
l'espace de toulouse l'occasion pour lui
de rencontrer un public passionné et
curieux quant à ses missions dans
l'espace regardez ce reportage de jean
marc lucas pour vyas occitanie
thomas pesquet le toulousain d'adoption
le spationaute chéri était devant son
public à la cité de l'espace des étoiles
plein les yeux pour des fans de conquis
des questions dans tous les sens tu vois
ton de la terre quand on est tous là
haut ou encore ça fait quoi d'être dans
une combinaison
tout ce qui fait dans l'espace toutes
les dettes et tout le tralala
comment ils flottent la pesanteur moi je
suis une gamine quand je l'entends
parler donc je trouve que pour les
enfants c'est génial il est câblé pour
être un grand spationaute et ça fait
rêver pas forcément parce
qu'effectivement on fera jamais ce qu'il
a fait
dans sa vie quoi et puis parfois face à
son héros on se montre humble est ce que
tu as envie d'être plus tard
spationautes aussi un métier qui touche
à l'espace mais peut-être pas trop là
bas
ça fait je trouve ça fait un peu
beaucoup ou
htc les entraînements
avec tout ça thomas pesquet après ses
missions iss devient le nouveau atteint
avec pour objectif la lune
comment intéresser les plus jeunes à la
littérature la problématique n'est pas
nouvelle et préoccupe les adultes à
l'heure des consoles et des smartphones
pour donner le goût de la lecture aux
jeunes générations la ville de calvi en
corse vient d'organiser un salon du
livre dédié à la jeunesse uniquement à l
cet auteur et illustrateur locaux
étaient notamment présents images et
interviews réalisées par benjamin kanak
manu verra pour vient télé pas aisé sur
l'île de beauté nous notre propos est de
développer cet amour de la littérature
dans la mesure aussi où non seulement
c'est la littérature plaisir mais c'est
aussi le goût des mots le goût de la de
la réflexion et à l'arrivée je dirais la
constitution d'un citoyen engagé dans la
société
voilà direction l'aube à présent dans
cette édition pour découvrir un bel élan
de solidarité
louis un petit garçon de deux ans
atteint d'une maladie rare passera un
été plus agréable grâce à la générosité
de donateurs sa maman que vous voyez sur
ces images de nos partenaires de l'est
éclair a lancé fin avril une cagnotte
pour équiper la maison d'une
climatisation bilan presque 8000 euros
récoltés en deux mois bien plus qu
imaginé au départ propos recueillis par
willy billiard regardez l ouïe donc est
habillé en fait en pantalon et en
tee-shirt manches longues toute l'année
pour le protéger de son environnement
pour pas qu'ils se cogne qui s'écorchent
et ses plus beaux coups de pansements
des genouillères et coudières voilà elle
appelle beaucoup de couches donc qui
fait qu'il joue déjà en premièrement de
la chaleur due à être trop habillée d'un
était beaucoup plus serein la
tranquillité d'esprit tu dire voilà le
soir
on peut n'est plus obligé de tout aéré
et encore quand il fait vraiment très
chaud n'a pas beaucoup on n'a pas
beaucoup d'air donc on met la clim on
est tranquille où il est au frais la
maladie sera moins présente on va dire
du coup cet été
voilà une bien belle histoire dans ce
journal est un très bon et est donc à
louis et à sa maman
cet été justement parlons-en vous
profiterez sûrement des vacances pour
passer du temps en famille ou entre amis
bien sûr autour d'un verre et bien
sachez que pour s'adapter au marché les
vignerons n'hésite pas à innover c'est
le cas d'un château en gironde qui vient
de lancer sa propre production de vin en
canette oui vous avez bien entendu en
canette logo non et emballages compris
tout a été pensé pour séduire un nouveau
public dont vous ferez peut-être partie
découverte sur place 10 vambre amphi
journalistes pour tv7 la chaîne du
groupe sud ouest
à l'oeil nu devin parfaitement
identiques mais un détail près leur
conditionnement d'origine l'un provient
d'une bouteille en verre le second d'une
canette en aluminium
c'est le fruit d'une idée plutôt
saugrenue qui a longtemps germé dans la
tête de sébastien fürth la sixième
génération de la famille à reprendre ce
domaine ça a été pendant le premier
confinement comme beaucoup il ya une
énorme remise en question donc on s'est
dit mais qu'est ce qu'on fait de tout ce
vin qu'on a dans les chais que plus
personne ne veut quasiment donc l'idée
est venue de là le bordeaux bashing la
mauvaise image des vins de bordeaux donc
on a créé une nouvelle gamme de vins un
vin monocépage en blanc rouge et rosé
lancé en 2020
d'abord dans une bouteille type
bourguignonne et plus récemment dans une
canette en aluminium afin de s'adapter
au marché actuel et d'initier une
clientèle un peu moins expérimentés là
on a préféré partir sur une sur un
personnage un peu un peu cheap hipster
des choses comme ça
ambiance un peu guinguette montrer
vraiment le côté un peu festif du vin et
donc c'est pour ça que c'était vraiment
un choix de notre part de ne pas mettre
de ne pas mettre le nom de le nom de
domaine c'est un nom plus original
gentleman vignerons pour marquer le
changement de gamme et casser les codes
de la bouteille traditionnel des
canettes produite sur place mais qui en
aucun cas ne prendront la place de leurs
grandes soeurs comme on a vingt hectares
de vignes ont fait à peu près entre 120
et 150 mille bouteilles par an
voilà sachant que ça fait à peu près
mille hectolitres de vin la sueur sur la
canette si on a fait 25 hectolitres de
canettes c'est tout donc voilà c'est
c'est un petit pourcentage par rapport à
ce que l'on produit habituellement soit
8000 kahn est produite chacune vendu
environ 3 euros 50 un prix d'appel car
l'objectif à long terme est d'installer
la can est comme une véritable
alternative à la bouteille en verre
et que ce soit en canettes ou en
bouteille ou en cuve même profité d'un
verre de vin dépend aussi du lieu de
dégustation en bretagne une cave à vin
en vrac vient de s'installer dans un
monastère oui un espace atypique et
apaisant comme a pu le constater claire
viallon de la rédaction de thé vert à
rennes
c'est un écrin de verdure en plein
centre ville de vitré le monastère saint
nicolas est pourtant resté longtemps
confidentiel mais depuis deux mois la
mairie nouvelle locataire des lieux a
décidé de proposer cet espace à des
porteurs de projets c'est avant tout du
temporaire pour occuper le site pendant
et bien toutes les réflexions autour de
la transformation futur mais l'idée de
la ville de vitré c'est de conserver
quelques volumes et notamment ceux qui
aujourd'hui sont affectés aux
différentes activités présentent quatre
projets ont pris place les ateliers de
teinture végétale penneteau ria la
troupe de théâtre la kanopé
l'association tous au berger etc à brac
une cave bar qui proposent du vin en
vrac donc voici nos deux belles cuves en
inox dans lesquels on retrouve notre vin
donc on a du vin de pays de loire parce
que en fait on n'avait pas envie d'aller
chercher nos vins trop loin toujours
pour une conscience un peu écolo donc on
a du chardonnay et un ans joue au rouge
qu'ils font
partie de la viticulture raisonnée et
donc en fait sont les cuves qui sont
sous azote pour la conservation du vin
pour pas qui s'oxydent et pour se servir
c'est très simple on a notre petite arba
bouteille là sont des bouteilles
consignées on ouvre le petit robin est
là et fait comme par magie le vin coule
à flots pour le moment myrtille et
guillaume occupent les lieux jusqu'à fin
décembre mais il espère bien pouvoir
pérenniser leurs projets quand on voit
le cas déjà pour venir travailler c'est
top et puis et puis c'est surtout aussi
les échos d'aidé créé un conte à quoi
qu'ils aient déjà nous disent qu'ils
n'ont pas envie qu'on bouge et que et
que le but est superbe donc ouais bien
sûr on aimerait rester ici réponse en
fin 2022 pour connaître l'avenir des
lieux en attendant le monastère saint
nicolas vous accueille du mardi au
dimanche et sera ouvert tout l'été
voilà et puis une pratique
traditionnelle pour refermer ce journal
la traction animale elle revient au goût
du jour dans nos campagnes porté par une
approche plus respectueuse de
l'environnement des agriculteurs
utilisent la force des animaux pour
labourer les champs exemple dans les
vosges où les boeufs était à l'honneur
il y a quelques jours fort comme un
boeuf on disait cela un sujet de marie
danielle rogowicz et dan didier pour
vosges télévision
c'était comme un retour dans le passé
une carte postale des pratiques
agricoles d'autrefois et pourtant la
traction animale n'a pas disparu en
france dont le village du valtin ce sont
les bleus qui étaient à l'honneur
philippe kullmann fermi alsacien forme
régulièrement de futurs bouvier qui doit
prendre la relève c'est sûr qu'on n'ira
pas du jour au lendemain et on ne va pas
retourner vers tout le travail fait avec
des animaux mais il ya quand même
une agriculture à deux vitesses qui
s'installe et de plus en plus de
personnes qui essayent de tendre vers
l'autonomie alimentaire pauline
ostéopathe elle souhaitait juste en
apprendre un peu plus sur les animaux le
guidage des boeufs attelé exige une
attention maximum et de la confiance en
soi pour ne pas se laisser dépasser par
la force des bovins
moi j'ai plus l'habitude de travailler
avec les chevaux donc c'est c'est
quelque chose qui est pas évident mais
je pense que c'est simplement une
question d'habitude quoi qu'ils ont de
la force et qui pousse un petit peu oui
en même temps ils ont un outil qui leur
demande d'avoir beaucoup de forces dans
la tête donc si c'est assez puissant il
faut quand même faire attention ils ont
une force colossale si si on fait une
erreur qu'on se trouve en train en
débardage si on évite pas ici sans plein
traction si tu trouves de annaba qui
viennent avec le joug qu'elin patres
quoi ça c'est sûr tu vas aussi au ciel
où on en fait à deux pas tres des
travaux des champs qui ont fait le
bonheur du public pour certains acteurs
d'un jour qui est plus naturelle parce
que j'étais un coeur bat ses records en
beauté pour des sens tu saurais les
arrêter
[Musique]
le village du valtin pour l an prochain
accueillir la rencontre nationale des
bouviers de france
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci d'avoir suivi cette
édition on se retrouve très vite pour
une prochaine édition aura tous
[Musique]
il